moving
it's never easy the packing and
unpacking having to start fresh and make
new friends
all this can be challenging but let's
face it whether it's a nasty landlord or
imminent threat to humanity sometimes
you just have to move in another one if
we looked at moving the earth to avoid
certain danger but what if that wasn't
enough what if we had to build a stellar
engine to move our entire solar system
how could we do it where would we go and
what would happen to us here on earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we moved the solar system to
move our solar system would require an
incredible amount of energy and careful
planning we could potentially do this
with a stellar engine a class of
hypothetical mega structures using a
star's radiation to create usable energy
thankfully with our planets locked in
orbit of the Sun due to its immense
gravitational pull we only have to find
a way to propel the Sun and our planets
and moons will follow Russian scientist
and aeronautical engineer Leonid
skate-off proposed an ingenious method
to move our Sun using a giant parabolic
mirror known as the shkadov thruster it
works by harnessing the sun's photons
and reflecting them back around the Sun
creating thrust each photon carries a
tiny amount of thrust meaning if you
were in space and you turned on a
flashlight he would eventually move just
very very slowly
the Sun produces 10 to the power of 45
photons per second this impressive
energy makes the Sun the most powerful
nuclear reactor ever as a result we
would have to position this parabolic
mirror exactly over the sun's poles to
avoid burning one of our nearby planets
this limits the direction we could move
and it would likely take us 230 million
years to move 100 light years that's an
astronomical amount of time so is there
a faster and more efficient way we could
move the Sun astrophysicist Matthew eke
a plan of Illinois State University has
proposed a new type of engine called the
Kaplan thruster this stellar engine
requires one quadrillion satellite
mirrors known as a Dyson swarm to orbit
the radius of the Sun these would
reflect the sun's energy in a
concentrated area heating it up and
shooting the sun's mass and solar winds
outward allowing us to utilize the
billions of tons of hydrogen and helium
collected using large electromagnetic
fields a thermonuclear reactor on board
could conceivably convert the helium and
hydrogen into radioactive oxygen used as
exhaust to propel the craft and any
leftover hydrogen from the Sun would be
shot in a jet of plasma using a particle
accelerator pushing the Sun forward and
keeping the thruster from being sucked
into the Sun's gravity this delicate
balancing act would allow us to move in
any direction we want at much greater
speeds the real challenge might be
building the Dyson Sphere itself for one
thing we would have to mine mercury for
its rich supply of metals and minerals
this would take a considerable amount of
time and effort but could provide us
with an almost infinite energy source
learn more about that in our other video
what if we built a Dyson Sphere
now what would it feel like on earth
when our entire solar system goes
surfing through space well turns out
everything might feel more or less the
same researchers at Illinois State
University believe that shifting the
solar system wouldn't disrupt our
planets orbits since the thrust of a
stellar engine would create just a small
acceleration overall as we orbit the Sun
the Sun orbits the galactic center of
the Milky Way we don't feel this
movement because it's constant if the
earth suddenly stopped moving however
we'd be in cosmic trouble with so many
travel destinations in the universe we'd
still be limited to only a small portion
of it known as the local group this
collection includes our massive Milky
Way galaxy the Andromeda and Triangulum
galaxies and about 50 other dwarf
galaxies now due to the mysterious force
of dark matter scientists have
discovered that the universe is rapidly
expanding even though we can see them
all the other galaxy groups are moving
farther away from us at speeds we'll
never be able to reach we'd be better
off looking for other habitable planets
like ours within our own galaxy in
approximately four and a half billion
years our Milky Way will eventually
collide with the Andromeda galaxy
forming milk dromeda at this point
galaxies outside the local group will be
so far away we won't even be able to
detect them like we can now future
civilizations born in the milk dromeda
universe may think that the local group
is all that there is they wouldn't be
able to learn about the Big Bang and may
think that the universe is static and
never-ending so consider yourself lucky
to be living at a time where we can
research the past and possible future of
our own universe maybe someday we will
harness our stellar energy and get to
explore our galaxy and make some new
friends along the way
this would make us a type two
civilization on the Kardashev scale
which measures a civilizations
technological ability to control and
utilize energy sadly we're barely a type
one civilization as we still haven't
figured out how to harness all of
Earth's available energy but that's a
story for another what-if